[BEEPS]
[GAME SOUND EFFECTS]
LILIANA YU: Welcome to
the first Cloud Labs
episode on the GCP
Essentials Quest
on Qwiklabs, Creating
a Virtual Machine.
In this quest, you get your
first hands-on experience
with Google Cloud, get
comfortable with the basics,
like spinning up a VM and
configuring key infrastructure
tools through working with
more advanced Stackdriver
and Kubernetes concepts.
You'll work your way
through each lab on Qwiklabs
until you have completed your
quest and received your badge.
You do not need a Google Cloud
Platform account or project.
An account, project,
and associated resources
are provided to you
as part of each lab.
Let's see what this
lab is about then.
Google Compute Engine lets
you create virtual machines
running different
operating systems,
including multiple
flavors of Linux--
Debian, Ubuntu, Red
Hat, and CoreOS--
and Windows Server on
Google infrastructure.
You can run thousands
of virtual CPUs
on a system that has
been designed to be fast
and to offer strong
consistency of performance.
In this hands-on
lab, you'll learn
how to create a virtual machine
instance using a Google Cloud
Platform console and using
the G-Cloud command line,
create a virtual machine with
deploy a web server and connect
it to a virtual machine.
It's helpful if you
have familiarity
with standard Linux text
editors, such as Vim, VMAX,
or Nano.
Google Compute Engine
is the foundation
to Google Cloud platform's
infrastructure as a service.
Next up on our quest is Compute
Engine, Qwik Start, Windows.
A quest is a series
of related labs
that form a learning
path on Qwiklabs.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
Good luck and have fun!
[MUSIC PLAYING]